j hat needs to be able to pitch inside
to all these right-handed hitters in
this yankee lineup
we need a quality start t twins need a
quality start they need it from jhap
right here
more action for the yankees right now
get this guy up at the plate with men on
base
mission accomplished stan a double and
two homers last night
stanton hits that in the air to center
indeed
celestino doesn't have a play
he's done it again perfectly balanced
and gone the straw stirring the drink a
three-run
shot for stanton and the yankees an
early three-nothing lead
when he gets hot this is kind of what it
looks like he's in the mouth of center
he's hitting him out to right he's
hitting him over 100 miles an hour and
it can be you know uh eight home runs in
12 games type of stretch that he can go
on
right on q meredith on a change up at 85
miles an hour actually a little slider
you see the spin
sitting right there and even though he's
a bit out in front the balance and his
legs are still underneath him
even though he's full just a bit
generates that kind of power
giancarlo no
parlo there's a ball driven to the right
field corner
kerala will play that off the wall it
bounces over his head
and carol off is down in the grass
rochelle to third and he will
go in with a stand up triple and we'll
see if carol off is okay
slow to get up well this is we see
max kepler's played so many games in
right field in this ballpark and he
plays as well as anyone
in his home ballpark and kiriloff looks
like that left ankle may have buckled a
little bit
infield was in now back at standard
depth for unduhar
out of the backstop
and he's safe
half slid across the plate
and i believe the call is safe but the
twins are going to take a look at it
take a look here oh yeah the bare hand
what an athletic player right there i
don't know
i don't think he ever got to the plate
and he tagged him with the bare hand
what an athletic play sliding catching
the ball bare-handed
having the awareness to turn put the tag
down
and i guess you can't really say i don't
know i don't even know the rule includes
pitchers blocking the plate
all right there was a tag with the glove
but then the bare hand came across with
the ball
and it doesn't look like he ever got to
the plate find out
in a moment out at the plate the inning
is over
but the yankees scored three on
stanton's third homer of this series
cruz with 25 runs batted in he's got a
nice hitting streak going now he's in a
great opportunity here
like that that ball
is caught and alertly tagging and
scoring is donaldson a sinking line
drive
and donaldson did an awfully nice job
staying
put in the unlikely event that that ball
was caught because
it was caught and duhar makes the diving
catch
fires in it'll be a sacrifice fly for
nelson cruz
but could have been much worse if not
for a really nice play from miguel and
duhar
and it's now a 3-1 game and that was a
great clean catch by a duhar in left
field
kiriloff has left the game celestino
taking over in right field
nick gordon is in center he appeared to
be
injured as he tried to play that ball
off the wall in the top of the first
inning so one out and now frazier
three and two nice pick
donaldson to second double play
a wicked one hopper donaldson played it
beautifully and started
and around the horn double play twins up
bottom two down to
3-1 new york and that'll bring up aaron
judge the yankees most consistent hitter
this year
a leaping catching left by trevor
larnick
a hooking line drive and larnick was
able to pull it down
for out number two nice play by lernick
right there going up and getting it
after three yankees on top by a score of
three to one
urshella crushes that uh-huh you know
where it's landing god
off the second deck geos starting to
flex his power
seventh over the season and the yankees
lead
4-1 you talk about just crushing it
and off the bat wow barrel off the
facade of the second deck
kittens drives that to right field and
deep
that ball is gone
chris kittens his first big league
hit is his first big league home run
says no first base umpire troop gibson
says yes
this is interesting this was a crew
chief review and they ruled
no home run but now they're putting on
the headset and it may be that aaron
boone has challenged this
balloon has challenged this at least it
appears they're going to go to new york
and new york will see
what we just showed you and maybe that's
the way it should all work it only took
about 10 seconds and i'm sure the people
in new york were
looking at it even before aaron boone
came out of the dugout so gideon saw
his first hit in the big leagues was a
two-run omer will reset
getting back in the box
we'll underhand it to suno would have
been an awkward throw to try to get the
lead runner at second base he took the
sure out that might have been the right
move to make
here come the twins down four to one
simmers 13 rubies on the year
that's to the gap left center field and
won't be caught
and it'll roll all the way to the
warning track
so no scoring good at bat for simmons
and it's 4-2
well just missed a double earlier in the
outback down the right field line ball
went foul kept the at-bat alive
and then splits the gap right here
drives in a run and two outs first and
second still
and we'll mayhew up mama you grounds it
up the middle of base hit center field
and do our rounding third he will score
it's a ribby single from dj lemay hue
and the yankees extend their lead to 5-2
little two-out magic comes right back in
there on the inside corner dj le mayhew
fights it off
thing about dj la mayhew is you can't
shift him he hits the ball the other way
all over the place so those ground balls
up the middle
are hits aaron judge with a single and
two line outs one to left one to right
out of donaldson at third and they get
the force at second to end the inning
the yankees will add one here in the top
half of the sixth inning and here comes
nelson cruz another two two driven hard
to left field
and down for a hit gordon will score
cruz will
round first head to second he's got an
rbi double
able to jog into second base and got
himself a little
a little slider in the middle of the
zone very similar location to the ball
with stanton hit out in the first inning
here he's able to
fall past and left finds in a run power
back to the plate and donaldson
one swing can change this game high fly
left center field going back as and
duhar
we are tied just like that donaldson
turned that one around hit it up in the
second deck
wow nelson cruz
driven to center field ball
huge comeback off a guy who's given up
basically nothing all year
four good at-bats four hard hit balls
and he knew it immediately ball game
over right there
what a moment here at target field with
the twins who've had their
hearts broken by the yankees so many
times in the ninth inning
striking for four runs to beat the
yankees seven
to five